okay
hello and welcome back everyone to the
road 2000. we had a little bit of a
false start there
um i expected a lot out of my
laptop here at home trying to stream
remotely and we had a little bit of lag
when i first went live but we're back
and everything should hopefully be
working a little bit better
so as i was saying the first time we are
going to go
over chess puzzles tonight and it's not
the kind of chess puzzles
that you are the most familiar with most
likely it's not the type of puzzles
you're going to find on leaches or
chess.com and their tactics trainers
i'm talking about composed chess studies
and beyond that we're even going to look
at some studies and some compositions
that go beyond what you would expect
from a normal
quote-unquote chess puzzle so without
further ado
we're a little bit late now so let's
just get into it so
i wanted to start with this composition
which i've actually
shown before uh on the channel so this
is actually a puzzle composed by
me so i came up with this one and i just
wanted to start with it briefly i've
shown it before
and i just want to show this as an
example of what a chess composition
might look like so right off the bat you
know this isn't what you're gonna find
in the lead chest tactics trainer of
course pieces are strewn about
in really crazy places all over the
board
and the goal of this type of puzzle
from the composer's point of view is to
come up with some kind of interesting
idea
that makes it worth the effort obviously
this isn't going to be the most
useful to find a tactical theme in your
own games
it's more about you know the the beauty
of solving it for yourself
um and so if you do want to try and
solve this puzzle
uh go ahead and pause the video now
because i'm not going to focus too much
on this one
it's not the best puzzle in the world
because i composed it and i'm not a
professional
chess problem composer but just to give
you an example of what we're kind of
dealing with
you know this is different than a normal
tactic because
it is such a crazy position and the
answer should be
equally kind of unique and interesting
so in this case we start off with the
normal move
the knight check and now the crazy move
queen g1 and the point here is that
black
was threatening to checkmate the white
king and
we uh need to divert this queen in order
to win
and sorry i'm doing a terrible job of
presenting this puzzle it was actually
maintenance seven
for white white to move in the initial
position but
um just kind of using this one as a
jumping off point i want to show off my
own puzzle
and so we pin the queen to the black
king the queen must capture
uh there's actually only one other legal
move and that's queen
to e3 that obviously fails sorry two
legal moves
rook d5 is also playable and the knight
moves are playable but they get check
rated so queen takes
and now uh if you want to try to solve
it from here as well this is maintenance
5
but the puzzle continues without further
ado knight b5 check
knight takes c3 knight b5 check
and finally last chance to try to solve
the puzzle for yourself
what was the point of everything well
the point now is that this queen
is out of play on g1 no longer
threatening
to checkmate us on c2 and we can play
the move
c3 effectively sealing the coffin on
this black king in the center
and black is now helpless to prevent the
checkmate and so no matter what's played
we get knight c7 and that is the
checkmate
that ends the study so obviously
this puzzle is a little bit convoluted
um but that's kind of the point for a
lot of these studies
uh and so hopefully you guys enjoy that
one a little bit but now let's jump into
the really crazy ones
so this position you know it's pretty
interesting
you know the king's stuck in the center
the knight hopping all around like that
and a queen sacrifice
pretty weird for a chest position but we
can get far weirder
and far more interesting don't you
worry and so without further ado let's
take a look at another
traditional chess puzzle in the form of
this one so when i say a traditional
chess puzzle here i'm talking about
the kind of puzzles that are still like
white to move in win
or black to move and win that that sort
of thing and that's what we have here
so this position white uh is
on the move and white can win
this game so you guys at home uh
take a minute see if you guys can find
it and
then i'll get into the solution and how
to find something
like a solution in a puzzle like these
so go on take a second and i'll let the
chat catch up here
and give me some of their ideas so white
to move and win
in this position where black has all
of their pieces remaining
raphael louise says h3
so give me an idea here h3 i think
you're gonna get killed right black has
the full army
play h3 black's gonna move the knight
start promoting start detangling
all these pieces and so yeah njf has
the correct first move of course so the
key here
is to realize that black is almost
completely stuck
despite having all of the pieces
on the board so obviously black is
moving downwards so all these pawns
are locked into place by the remainder
of the pieces
you know all of them have a piece in
front of them this knight is also
immobilized by the other pieces
this bishop is immobilized by these two
pawns
this rook is immobilized by the four
pieces around it
this rook this bishop this king all
as well immobilized and the only piece
that's truly free
is this knight on e1 so white's going to
play king takes c1 here
and after that much to black's sugar in
black is not in stillmate and is not
drawing the game
uh because of course this queen has one
legal move it's locked in
by these surrounding pieces but this one
open square
does give black a legal move and so
black is going to have to play queen to
a1 and unfortunately for black moving
this queen
doesn't really release any of the other
pieces
so now we have to continue here we have
to continue so how can we continue
and try to get the checkmate
how can we continue this
oh i'm messing up the cropping a little
bit that's okay
and wow you guys are just too
clever for this puzzle so
you find the first move pretty easily
here you find king takes e1 because
otherwise the knight's gonna move
and then you know you promote the pawn
as black you start getting all the
pieces into the game
and there's no way white can survive but
the second part of this puzzle i think
is sort of the harder part where you
have to realize now okay
so as white i've got black moving back
and forth forever and ever and ever
how do i actually check me and since
black has so many pieces and this king
is so well fortified
you know a queen is actually not gonna
get the job done here
uh a queen and a king are not gonna be
enough to checkmate this king
when all of these squares surrounding
the king
are defended you know so well right you
just you can't really break in
with a queen and a king so you need a
piece that's a little bit better at
jumping of course so that's how you can
kind of arrive at the idea
of promoting to a night which of course
has to be done
and then the people in the chat room
have actually gone all the way through
to the end um or perhaps guessed
and found the key difference to this
puzzle
so there's a question should white play
h4
or h3 or does it matter if you want to
try to figure it out for yourself
pause here because the chat room is way
ahead of me on this one
of course you need to play the move h3
and how did the tactics work out well
you had to calculate pretty deeply on
this one
of course black has only one legal move
in all of these positions
and white has only one option as well we
create our knight on the eighth rank
and now we begin our night hops
and we have to start taking some pieces
so
how are we going to checkmate this black
king
well we can't checkmate it with knight
takes
on e oh sorry on d3 here because this
rook defends
same with e2 and a2 is going to be too
tough to get to
it's just too well defended uh so
there's no access points
and that of course leaves the g6 square
so we need
to play knight takes g6 in some manner
in order to win the game
but first of course we have to remove a
couple pawns
so that's why we're taking this long
route we're gonna take here
we're gonna maneuver and capture this
one
and still even with these two pawns gone
black
cannot escape his fate and after knight
a5
black is zogged must play queen to a1
and we get knight takes b3 checkmate so
this one pretty unique pretty
interesting how a single king
and pawn at first and then night later
are enough to defeat black's entire army
in this specific setup
really really interesting stuff but
uh i'm not happy even with these crazy
compositions we can get
stranger we can get more unique so
let's now take a look at something
called retrograde
analysis puzzles so most puzzles even
compositions like this
all start where you would expect at the
beginning
of the puzzle but one of my favorite
types of chess puzzles that's
non-standard rather than just crazy
compositions are these retrograde
analysis
puzzles and what makes them interesting
is that they start
at the end uh and so this position
is actually the final position of this
chess puzzle
and the challenge is to use retrograde
analysis or sort of
you know i got i don't know how to
define retrograde analysis it's when you
start at the end
and have to think backwards um more or
less
not the real definition obviously uh but
essentially that's the heart of it
so we're starting at the end and the
challenge is
this is the position after move for
how was it achieved so you have the
final position
you start from the initial position in
chess and you have to try to figure out
how did we get here and when i say after
move four i have to be very very
specific
it is after black's fourth move that we
have achieved
this position so white has played four
moves and black has played
four moves so next up would be white's
fifth move which could be anything
knight f3 any move could be uh
could be played here um
and so if you guys are in here in the
live chat
go ahead take a moment and try to ponder
it over and then i'll sort of walk you
through
some kind of a solving process and we'll
go step by step try and figure out how
we can find a solution but while you
guys are
getting acquainted with this puzzle and
starting to think about it
uh i want to talk to you a little bit
about retrograde analysis puzzles
um there is a man by the name of raymond
sullivan who was one of the first to
really popularize
these kinds of puzzles in a series of
books that he did
with the character sherlock holmes so if
you guys are interested in these kinds
of puzzles i would highly recommend
checking out some of those books i think
raymond sullivan actually passed away a
few years back
but uh really interesting puzzles in
those books
um and i wanted to give his legacy
a little bit of a shout out here
so isaac actually has the right answer
but the youtube
auto mod system doesn't allow it in the
chat
and so since isaac solved it so quickly
i'm fairly confident
he had seen this puzzle before so i'm
not going to show that one
i'm gonna keep it hidden for the uh
for the other viewers here to keep
taking a look at it so of course if
you've seen the puzzle before
you're gonna know the answer please
don't spoil it for anybody
oh and good morning gamortis uh has a
question on the previous one
about the pawn capturing the knight so i
think you were looking at the board
backwards if you rewind
then the uh the black pawns were moving
downwards so they couldn't capture they
were moving upwards
could have captured but they were stuck
moving down the board
uh all right so the chat seems
reasonably stumped
on this one for the moment so let's take
a look
and just start playing some moves right
let's start playing some moves don't
forget
this is our goal here so let's take note
of the features we have the white pawn
on e4
the white bishop on f1 is actually
missing
this black pawn on
uh d7 is also missing and we have the
black pawns
shifted to c6 and e6
and not to be misleading here we of
course don't know
that it's actually the d pawn that got
captured the d-pawn
could have recaptured on one of these
squares for example we just know
currently black has a pawn on c6 and e6
no pawn on the d file and white is
missing a bishop on
f1 so this is a lot to try to achieve in
four
moves or at least it would be until you
just start playing it out
there is there only one way there is in
fact only one way raphael to do it
in four moves exactly four complete
moves
so let's start with some things that are
not the solution
so what's the first move well obviously
white needs to move the e
pawn no other piece is removed in the uh
final position so we should should move
the z pawn i see no reason to play e3
yet we're just trying to get a good feel
for the puzzle so let's think about
playing
e4 here um so we're gonna play e4
and then as black you know the d pawn's
gone
we have the the pawn shifted to c6 and
e6 it makes sense to try
and just set up the position right so
we're going to play e6
now we need to get rid of this bishop
and get rid of this d-pawn
and put this pawn to c6 and we have
three full moves
to do it so chat room who has any ideas
on what to do in this position
here
oh and we're lagging a bit apparently um
i shut off the computer to make sure
we're all on the up and up here had the
engine running for no reason the
engine's not going to solve this puzzle
so i don't know why i had it running
but uh yeah i think we should be good
now
it stopped now all right thank you i'll
be enough
so raphael has an interesting idea so
rather than actually try and capture the
d-pawn
with something like this raphael perhaps
realized this is gonna take way too long
right
if we do this we've achieved the
position but this is actually after
five full moves so rafael came up with a
really great idea um and abhinav came up
with a really great idea
to save some time on this idea so
abhinav's idea or sorry raphael's idea
was to capture
on e6 and this way we have achieved the
position
uh there's only one problem now and that
is we achieved the position after
three full moves and with one move a
piece
uh passing of course is not allowed in
chess
and so we're gonna have to ruin our
beautiful position and now abhinav's
idea
was essentially the same it was to put
the bishop on b5
and capture on c6 but this again
has the same problem uh it's only been
three full moves not four
full moves and so this is actually not a
real solution
this isn't going to be good enough uh
and of course
you know passing's not allowed we have
to ruin the position
somehow right so we need to be a little
bit more clever
than this so my first thought at least
when approaching this was well
why don't i try wasting a tempo with
white i'll play something like e3
and then we'll try to do you know
something
similar here and with this
i've achieved the position uh after
three and a half moves not four full
moves so of course in this position
it is black to play and our goal
position
is after move four and it is white's
turn here not black's turn so we haven't
quite done it still so i've sort of set
you guys up
with the obvious points of the puzzle
these are the things that you can sort
of intuitively work out
but the puzzle wouldn't be that
interesting if all you had to figure out
is that you're capturing on e6
so we need something even crazier
so how can we do it guys how can we do
it
how can we find four full moves
to achieve our final position and i'll
put that final position
up on the board for you for a few more
seconds so now is a good point
now that you have some background on how
to start the thinking process on the
puzzle
now would be a good point to pause again
if you don't want it spoiled because i'm
going to start giving away some pretty
big hints here
so njf keeps saying bishop a6 but of
course
um any way of losing the bishop like
this
is going to be way too inefficient
because
black still has a d pawn in this
position and so
even if you got to here this would be
four full moves
but black still has the d pawn of course
um alright so let me start giving away
some hints then
uh so we know some things about the
puzzle we know
we have four moves to achieve our goal
no more and no less and we know
that one move as black has to be spent
on playing the move e6
and one move has to be spent on playing
the move c6
right there's no way to get around this
we have to play both of these moves
now how do i know that well if the pawns
didn't move from
e7 and e6 then they would have to be
captured on their initial squares and we
just can't do that
in four moves uh and so levy has a very
interesting idea so we know
that one move is spent on each of these
moves
putting the pawn on e6 putting the pawn
on c6 we don't know what happened to the
d-pawn yet but we know for a fact
black has spent time on these two moves
what else do we know for a fact well we
know for a fact
that white spends at least one turn
moving this pawn out to e4
and at least a second turn developing
this bishop
to you know some square and at least a
third turn sacrificing it for something
else
and then we actually need to waste a
fourth tempo which we could do
by moving this pawn to e3 and then e4 or
we could do by moving an extra turn
with our bishop somehow so the question
is
we've seen that e4 e6 bishop c4
c6 bishop takes pawn takes is not going
to be good enough
because it's an odd number of moves it's
three moves and we can't reset
to our initial position so
the trick is to find out with these two
moves in mind
to find two other moves for black that
get us back to the initial position
and of course this means that black's
other two moves
have to be moving back and forth there's
no other way
to have an even number of moves and you
know get back to the same position
so black has to do something like knight
h6 knight g8
something like queen e7 queen d8 bishop
d7 bishop
c8 something like that in order
to get the position and so that is the
massive hint
that i have for you two of black's moves
are e6 and c6
and black's two other moves have to be
moving
some piece back and forth
now the question is what piece
is that going to be so raphael has
another interesting idea
to combine with levees now that we know
that black has to move back and forth
with his piece
we know that this d-pawn cannot have
moved this d-pawn simply cannot have
moved
and that tells us that we must be
capturing it
on d7 and that is going to lead us
directly
to the solution let's take a look
we have e4 and i'm going to start with
e6 to keep this diagonal open
bishop b5 and now who from this position
can tell me the solution to the puzzle
who can tell me the solution
we have to move some piece back and
forth
to get the position after four full
moves
all right i believe in you people i
think you can do it
i think you've got it from here
so everybody knows we have to take on d7
and play c6 after the question is
what is the passing move for black
how can you effectively pass and
with that i'm going to start going over
the wrong answer i saw in the chat which
is everybody saying queen e7 and of
course this one is
not quite good enough for the simple
reason being
you know it has to be a legal game of
chess and after bishop takes d7
unfortunately we must capture this piece
and now white would have to move some
other piece and we actually have quite a
bit of work to do to get back to our
initial position
this of course would be five full moves
five full moves so
how can we make it so that this
check doesn't ruin our day yes
abhinav has the correct answer isaac in
the chat also dropping some helpful
hints
king to e7 is the key and now
we take off the d pawn and after the
move c6
of course the last move of the puzzle
drum roll is bishop e8
king takes e8 and we have achieved
on move four our uh
our goal our goal position and this is
the only way to get there in four moves
just to show you one more time
we're gonna count one move by white one
move by black
move two move three and move
four there you are so really clever
stuff
these retrograde analysis puzzles now
i'm gonna show you another kind
of retrograde analysis puzzle that i
found to be very interesting it's a
pretty famous one so if you're at all
familiar
with retro puzzles you'll probably have
seen this one as well
and then we're going to move into some
puzzles i can almost guarantee nobody in
the chat room has seen and i'm very
excited for
it very excited so the question
in this puzzle um is pretty obvious
it's where's the white king what
happened to that guy
uh so the setup for this puzzle is
basically
we have taken some legal chess position
there was a legal chess position
and we have hidden the white king
so the white king is somewhere on this
board
we've just made him invisible so the
puzzle is
can you figure out in this legal chess
position
where is the white king where has he
gone
and then of course a little bit of
explanation as to how
he got there that is the puzzle
so if you want the puzzle from you know
the the pure initial
um with no hints there it is
where is the white king and how did he
legally get there
and yeah levi in the chat sorry i was
calling him levy
been watching too much twitch chess um
levi in the chat has seen this before
um and yeah i would argue this is one of
the most famous
retro puzzles but after this we're gonna
get into the real deep stuff
um a6 has been suggested
so right away um i'm gonna start
dropping some hints here because i think
a lot of people have seen this one
before
let's start dropping some hints so what
do we notice we notice that this
king is in check right hopefully we all
notice this so
the key is to start you know figuring
out what are
the constraints we're working with well
the black king's in check
so you have to ask yourself how did it
get put
into check how was the black king in
shack what was white's last move
well this bishop obviously did not come
from this diagonal
because there's a rook in the way and
it's not like the bishop could have
captured a piece to put black into check
and so
the question chat room is how was black
in check
that is your starting point that's where
you start thinking with this one
how do we put the black king into check
legally
of course this is a legal chess position
with the king
for white being invisible
so how is black in check
so alex has suggested a three abhinav
has suggested b3
so of course uh i'm sorry i apologize i
might be
i might have misled you the position is
black to move
and white's king is missing position is
black to move
and white's king is missing um
and so of course having the white king
on b3
would be illegal because number one
blight would be in check
number two white would be an illegal
double check there would be no way to
construct that
so the question is you know where's
white's king so what am i
talking about as far as this check well
of course of course of course
we have put the king into check via
discovery
the king is in a discovered check
because our king
likely used to be on b3 and then moved
off
either to a3 or c3
so there you go puzzle solved it's
either on
a3 or c3 but of course the puzzle is not
solved
because there is only one place this
king could be
and that's where the real challenge
begins how
do we determine whether or not the king
is on c3
or a3 how can we figure this out
um so with that hints
with that hint chat room does anybody
have the solution
um i'm thinking maybe not unless i give
you guys a lot of time so if you want to
try to figure it out from there
go ahead and pause the video and uh
and unpause with with some other stuff
but
so how do we figure out whether it's on
a3 or c3 well it has to do
with this seemingly impossible double
check
from our king being on b3
right our king had to be on b3 so it
could move and deliver this check to the
black king we know that for effect it
had to be on b3
but how did the king come to be in this
strange looking
double check on b3 that's the challenge
so you use this double check against the
king on b3
to try and figure out some way that the
position could have happened from here
and then that'll tell you which way the
king had to move whether it went to a3
or c3 so
how do double checks happen well they
happen when
um a piece is suddenly removed right
when a piece is removed
usually you move a piece out of the way
and
that results in a check sorry that's how
discovered checks happen
and so a double check usually happens
when you know you move one piece and
then attack the king with that same
piece but there's
actually a second way we can put a king
into double check and it's using a
pretty interesting
and pretty unique rule in the game of
chess
so with those pretty hefty hints
does anybody have an idea as to what i
might be talking about
does anybody have an idea i think
isaac's got this one
i think isaac's got this one
and yes alex has the right answer the
king
of course must be on c3
in this position and to show you how it
happens i'm going to reveal
um this perfectly legal chest position
so
nothing out of the ordinary here um all
these pieces are on
very normal squares nobody's in check
nobody's in double check
but here you can imagine that black
played the move bishop d5
check white wanted to get out of check
and played the move c4
and then of course black takes on facant
putting this king
into this seemingly impossible double
check
and now white plays of course king takes
c3
check to the black king and we have
our location of the white king and this
is the only way
you can actually place this white king
it cannot be anywhere else
you can't do any funny on-pissant stuff
on the other side
because the bishop is checking from this
side
and so on passant and king takes
gives you our location of the white king
it belongs right there
on c3 um
and funny story for the people in the
chat room when i was setting up this
puzzle on my lead chest study
i wasn't quite sure how to set up a
position without a white king
so this is actually anti-chess nobody
saw it coming but this is actually
anti-chess
and of course black wins by force
with this series of moves just just so
you all know um
fun fact okay with that i am going to
stop
doing these pure retrograde puzzles and
introduce yet another super interesting
rule so these are the puzzles
i'm pretty confident nobody in the chat
room
has seen before so now that we're all
super comfortable
with chess positions where you can't see
one of the kings
take a look at this one take a look at
this one
and what this is is a really interesting
kriegspiel puzzle so not quite chess
it's a chess
variant puzzle and what is creekspiel
well you don't really need to understand
the full game
to understand this puzzle which is why i
selected it but
essentially all of your opponent's
pieces
are completely invisible
and for the purposes of this puzzle um
whenever you make a move there is some
arbiter who tells you
if your move is legal if your move is
illegal because there's like a piece in
the way or something
and the arbiter tells you if you've
captured something the arbiter
also will tell you if you have put the
enemy king
into check so you don't know where the
king is the arbiter will tell you
if you've put the king into check and
from which direction
you've put it into check so for example
let's take a look at one possibility
here let's say
the white the black king was on a one
so if you as the white player tried to
move rook f1
it would be legal the arbiter would tell
you rook f1
horizontal check the king has been put
into check from the horizontal position
now if you played the move bishop d4 the
arbiter would tell you
bishop d4 diagonal check long diagonal
check
in this case um and so those are the
rules we're dealing with
uh we don't know where any of the black
pieces
are we do know these little bits of
information that the arbiter tells us
tells us if we have a legal uh pawn
capture tells us if we've captured
anything
and it tells us if we've put the enemy
king into check and from which direction
that's what we know after every move
in this initial puzzle it is actually
checkmate in two
by force and we don't
know anything about where the black king
is
where any other black pieces might
be and that is the puzzle so
your job is determine a way to check
mate in two
regardless of where the black pieces
are not such an easy task not such an
easy task
so chat room if everybody understands
the puzzle
go ahead take a moment here and try and
figure out
some potential ideas
try and figure out some potential ideas
so this is like battleship except it's
chess
kind of it's called kriegspiel it's an
incredibly fun game
um and it's incredibly interesting for
chess puzzles
where is the black king that's the
question njf we don't know
we don't know could be almost anywhere
uh so of course njf's rather obvious
question is actually a great place to
start with the puzzle
so as my first hint we're gonna try to
determine
where this black king possibly could be
so of course
you know it's white to move so black is
not presently in check
and black of course this king cannot be
on a square where our pieces are
so that narrows it down of course we
have a lot of squares on the board
already under control i'm not going to
bother to highlight them all
of course or maybe i am so of course we
have all of these squares
either under control or occupied right
so many squares under control or
occupied
just looking at all the pieces right
we just control so many gosh darn
squares
um so that doesn't leave many places
for this black king to be
so let's highlight first the unoccupied
squares and unattacked squares
so these are the squares that aren't
occupied by any white pieces and
aren't attacked by any white pieces so
this is a good starting point
for where the king to be for where the
king could be
so who can identify a potential problem
square here
and we'll see if we can do something
about it what could a problem square be
for us
what could a problem square be
so we don't know which of these squares
the black king is on
it looks as though the black king could
be
on any of them so jacques says h8
and i would actually argue that h1
could be the problem square now what's
the reason for that
well on all these other squares black
would always have a legal move
right on c4 c6 black could capture the
bishop for example
on h5 it could capture the the h6 upon
h8 it moves to h7
h7 it can take h6 these squares
obviously all connected but h1
there's no legal moves for that black
king so if we try to play some kind of
move that influences
like the c4 square like um this person
with the
name i can't read says if we play
something like rogue four
the king on h1 would be stalemated of
course it's not mate in two
if you still mate your opponent so we
could potentially
uh not solve the puzzle there um
but it turns out we can actually
eliminate
the h1 square
uh now why can we eliminate the h1
square well because
black could not have played a previous
move
we could not have played a legal
previous move with the king
being on h1 um and great wolf
has another great thing that perhaps is
what i should have started with
we already know that the black king is
down to one of these locations
but what about the rest of the black
pieces where the rest of the black
pieces and so that is probably the first
thing we should look at here
and so how do we know how many black
pieces are left well you take a look at
this
rather unique pawn structure for white
and you start to realize
that quite a few pawn captures have been
played so for example
one pawn capture 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15
pawn captures of course there are only
16 pieces
on a chessboard so we do actually know
for a fact
that the king is the only piece
remaining for black
now as i was saying we can eliminate the
h1 square because there would not be a
legal
previous move for the chess game
if the king was on h1
we are told that we captured them all by
the arbiter but more importantly than
that
just to achieve this position the pawn
has to move diagonally
and so they have all been captured we
know that just by looking at the
position regardless of any
information given
uh wouldn't c4 and c6 be possible yes so
we've got those on the board but h1 not
possible
and the reason for that is we control
every square around this
king twice and what that means is that
this king
could not have come from any of these
squares because
these squares would have all been
defended no matter what white's previous
move was no matter what white's previous
move was the king could not have come
from there because that square would
have been defended anyways
hopefully that makes sense so h1 is
effectively limited eight not the same
with h5 because you can imagine
the king was on h4 white played queen g3
check black played
king h5 that would be legal that would
be legal
um so we have all of these squares left
on the board and it doesn't look like
we can eliminate them anymore so the
question is
how can we checkmate the king by force
regardless
of where this king is so
how do we go about solving this now that
we've eliminated
h1 and we are sure that the king is the
only piece left on the board
that means the king is on c4 or c6
because anywhere else could be
a mate in one so not necessarily dominic
the
puzzle is that you should be able to
force
checkmate no matter where the king is um
and
in at most two moves so you sort of have
to checkmate all of these kings
at once um of course though after your
first move
you can potentially get more information
on where the black king is located
and you can use that to adapt your
second move depending on where it is
so step one is basically locate the
black king
step two is checkmate the black king no
matter where
it's at so what tools are at our
disposal of course
we are told if we put the black king
into check
so we should be looking at moves that
could potentially put the black king
into check
and we are also told if the black king
captures one of our pieces first of all
it disappears
and um
you know and second of all we're just
we're told that it disappears
so those are our two main tools for
locating the black
king so a few things can happen
number one we can move and we're not
told anything we didn't put the king
into check and the black king doesn't
capture one of our pieces
number two we move we're not told
anything and then we're told that the
black king captures one of our pieces
that's really easy obviously because we
know exactly where the king is
because it captured one of our pieces or
number three we move and we're told that
we put the king
into check and from which direction we
put it into check
so using those three things you have to
sort of locate
where this king is
so queen g1 removes a lot of squares
that's true
so queen g1 would be a pretty
informative move
um either we're told we've put our
opponent into checkmate
in which case great we did it or
we're not told anything and we know that
the black king is on one of these five
squares
so then the question is do we have a
checkmate after
black's next move well if we aren't told
anything
after black's next move we know it has
to have moved between h7
and h8 because it didn't capture a piece
and black's only legal moves all capture
pieces on these other three squares
and we can play queen g7 mate which is
great
so we did it there but unfortunately
what happens if black plays king takes
h6 do we have a checkmate there
i'm not so sure that we do not so sure
that we do
we might but i i really don't think so
rook h2 you think um in the initial
position
ah so abhinav has an interesting idea
abhinav wants to try to play
h7 so we might not be able to play h7
but we can try to play h7 now why might
we be able to play it well it could be
illegal if the king is on h7 so we could
try it
the arbiter would tell us that h7 is
legal uh
and then we could play queen g7 mate or
after we try it it would get played
if it is legal and then uh we would have
more information but the question is do
we have
checkmate after age seven if the king
isn't on age h7
do we have checkmate and i'm not sure
that we do i'm not sure that we do for
um many of these uh
of these potential king positions for
example
if the king is on h8 we play h7 and then
king takes h7
i don't think we have a checkmate there
uh just to name
one example um so i'm not super sure
how to give more hints than this
for the puzzle without just giving away
some really big details so if you do
want to try to solve this one on your
own
i would recommend it but uh i am going
to start giving away
some pretty big stuff now some pretty
big stuff
so obviously we know the king
is in one of these three spots and so we
want sort of
each of our different things uh each of
our different bits of information
that we can get to tell us to identify
one of
you know these locations so
um right now there's not much difference
not much way
for us to tell the difference between a
king moving between h8 and h7
and a king moving between b1 and
c1 so this is a key problem
that we need to solve for example if we
did play something like rook h2
and then black plays some move we don't
know what it is
uh and we're not told anything we're not
sure if black just played king h8 or if
black just played king b1
and you can't checkmate both of those
kings at the same time
um you know without that information
right
you can checkmate one of them but um
you have to it's kind of a 50 50 guess
right you don't know where it is
so that's the problem with rook h2 is
because oh my god
it's because we need some way to
identify where the black king is
and after rook h2 there's no way for us
to determine the difference
between a king moving between c1 and d1
in a king moving between h8 and h7
so you have to use these tools to locate
the black
king with your first move uh jared says
knight g5 then
and this is closer to the right
idea we need to somehow eliminate
this king h8 king h7 shuffling maneuver
so that way if we're not told any
information
we know for a fact that the king is down
here
now um okay so you're saying knight g5
on
move two well the problem is it's white
to move in and mate in two this is a
checkmate and two puzzle
and so knight g5 being your second move
might tell you where the king is but it
doesn't
you know deliver the checkmate uh and
with knight g5 perhaps a potential
problem
is what if this king is on h5 and then
moves to g6
no checkmate there as far as i'm aware
and we're also not sure if the king is
on g6 h5
or on c1 or d1 again
so yeah knight g5 on move one imagine
the king is on h5
and king g6 is played we would be told
no information
and we have no way to see if the king is
on g6
or on the first rank and you can't
deliver checkmate to both at the same
time
queen d3 okay so now i'm going to start
giving big things away because we can
sit here
and play this guessing game all day but
i'm gonna show you
one wrong solution that will hopefully
lead you
to the correct solution so no one is
utilizing all these beautiful pawns
on the seventh rank why is nobody
promoting these guys
so i am going to um
promote this pawn to a queen
and this is going to tell me a lot of
information
because if the king was on h8 i would be
told that we have put the black king
into check
via a horizontal check um
now of course if the king were on h8 it
would have to move to h7
and we could play queen g7 mate that
would be
fantastic the king were on h7 it can no
longer shuffle back to h8
and so it would have to capture on h6
in which case i can checkmate and if
we're told no information after queen
to d8 then we know for a fact that the
king is on the first
rank and we can play queen g1 mate
um so d8 queen seemingly
is effective at eliminating all of the
potential moves
for black right we know exactly where
it's going to be
either black will capture on c5
black will capture on h6 or we will not
be told any information
and the black king is on the first rank
against king c5
we have queen c3 mate against king takes
h6
we have queen h8 mate and if king h8 to
h7
where we know it's on h7 because we put
the king into check and we deliver
checkmate so there you go seems to be
the perfect
solution to everything but
what is the problem with d8 queen of
course d8 queen
has a very nasty
problem that makes it the incorrect
solution
who can find the idea and yeah alex and
perhaps lauren in the chat as well
both see the issue and the issue is if
the king were on
e1 um and i can
sort of show this to you we're gonna put
the king over here on e1 i did set up
some positions
with the king then d8 queen
would be stalemates and that would be a
puzzle failure so d8 queen
is not going to be good enough
so what's better than d8 queen chatroom
what's the solution to this puzzle
what happened with the king being on c4
c6 well in the d8 queen scenario
the king on c4 or c6 would only have one
legal move
that's to capture on c5 right this king
cannot go to any of these squares
um this king cannot go to any of these
squares so both kings would end up on c5
and then we play queen c3 mate
so jared says ca avinash is c8 series is
c8
mitchell walters says b8 d8 equals
night has been suggested but of course
there is only one solution
to this puzzle so i'll let you guys at
home
uh think a little bit more about the
difference between all of these
um pawn promotions
what is the solution to all of these
pawn
promotions
so yeah i've eliminated one option for
you i've eliminated one option d8 queen
is not it but between these three
only one promotion will work
so jared has eliminated c8 because
if the black king is on c4 and we play
c8 queen
that is stalemate to the queen so
pawn to c8 equals queen has been
eliminated
stalemate if the king is on c6 well if
the king's on c6 c8 queen would be
checkmate which is great
but if the king is on c4 then it is
actually stalemate so we cannot play c8
queen
so the question is b8 or a8 which one
works and which one doesn't
so everybody's saying one of them but
why doesn't the other one work
so aegis um actually not quite because
you do get more
information than that sorry if that
wasn't clear so the arbiter tells you
that the black king is in check and it
actually tells you which direction
it's in check from so it'll say
horizontal check or file check
rank check or file check so you would be
able to determine for that
but as pippa now says and plenty of
people in the chat
if the king were on a1 then b8 queen
would in fact be a draw so this one that
i already had set up actually
is why ba queen will not work so
that leaves us with a8 queen as our
solution
and that is actually the only way to
force mate in two no matter where this
black king is so
really difficult puzzle these creek
spiel puzzles i really enjoy them though
they're fun to wrap your head around so
just to show you a few possibilities
the king were on a1 we would play a8
queen
king b1 would be played we would not
know where the king is
for certain but we would know that the
king is on the first rank
and we could play queen g1 check uh
checkmate
with confidence if the king were over on
c4
we play a8 queen black has no legal
moves aside from capturing this
bishop now since our bishop is has
disappeared we know the king's on c5
and we play queen to c3 checkmate and
one more
if we play a8 equals queen and
king takes h6 is played regardless from
where it started
now we have queen h8 mate and just to
show you
um the final one
if the king is on h8 and we play a8
queen we are told
horizontal check king h7 is the only
legal move and we follow this up
with queen to g7 mate checkmating
this king no matter where he started
from
so really fun puzzle i really enjoy
these creek spiel puzzles
if you guys want a fun challenge to take
home with you
i'm going to leave you with uh two
puzzles actually
this one is similarly a matin two
uh just like the one we just tried same
rules and everything
um so i will leave you with this one and
one more puzzle for you guys
this one is actually um checkmate
in six moves white to move checkmate in
six moves
and here it's the same type of puzzle
as the previous two but you know the
king's starting position
so you don't know any of your opponent's
following moves you have to use
this information gathering system to try
and checkmate the king and six moves
no matter where your opponent has gone
really difficult stuff so let me know in
the comments if you are
able to solve these at home uh hopefully
you enjoyed
these interesting puzzles they're wildly
different from
the chess puzzles we're all probably
used to but i have a lot of fun looking
at these thinking about these
and hopefully you did as well if you're
watching live we do actually have
another class coming up after this
with darrow sweets so stay tuned for
that
on the channel but that is actually all
i have for you tonight so thank you all
so much for watching thank you so much
for melting your brains with me here
tonight
uh as always my name is caleb denby and
i will see you guys next time
goodbye
you